[Music]
welcome to
session 50 in the worlds of speculative
fiction series this
is a talk a lecture and discussion
series
that has been going on now it's in its
sixth year
and originally it started out as a
face-to-face gathering at the brookfield
public library a monthly
series where we'd focus on narrative
worlds and philosophical themes in
particular
speculative fiction authors with covid
we've gone online and so
we do these videos and then we follow
them up with
some more in-depth intensive and
engaging zoom sessions and
i made a little change to this
particular session
i originally had it scheduled that we
were going to try to go through
this entire trilogy by r
scott backer the prince of nothing
series
and as i began to re-read
the darkness that comes before i i
realize that
no that's way too much to try to take on
in a single session so what we're going
to do
is this session is going to be devoted
entirely to the first book in the series
the darkness
that comes before and then we'll do
another
subsequent one on the warrior prophet
and then finish it up
with the thousand-fold thought so we're
actually devoting
one quarter of the year to our scott
backers
first part of his second apocalypse
series because there are four other
books coming
after that in a uh you know
second uh series so we're just focusing
on the
first trilogy and the reason that i
i it's not just a matter of length that
made me decide that we need to spend
the entire session just on this book
it's also how incredibly
rich and dense and complex and
philosophically
oriented the world building is
and the philosophical themes are in this
this work particularly through
some you know rather conventional ways
of introducing ideas you know with the
little selections
uh from philosophers who our scott
backer has created
or the history of of the events with uh
akhmanian
one of the main characters writing it
but also all the discourses that are
going on
with these characters there's so much
going on that in order to really do
justice to it and to introduce people
well to the series which i highly
recommend you read it's
it's really quite wonderful we really
need to
focus on one book at a time and take
them a bit slower than we might if it
was
a different writer and a different
trilogy
so as usual we're going to talk a lot
about the book itself
but we're also going to discuss the
biography
of the author in this case a still
living and still relatively young
author just a few years older than me
and we're going to also talk about the
world building itself and how that
in some respects comes out of his
biography in interesting ways
and then we'll jump into the
philosophical themes
um much of what we're going to do here
is laying the groundwork for talking
about these
other two in our subsequent
follow-up sessions which would be number
51 and 52
devoted to these two books as well and
the
ongoing developments so
there's a lot to cover and let's jump
right in
with our scott backer his biography
is a natural starting point for
several different reasons which we'll
we'll go into
here the first reason is that
it's an unfinished biography and there's
a lot of things sort of left
open within how how it's going
and that kind of parallels the
set of books that this trilogy is a part
of
and then the follow-up four volumes the
unholy consult because
there's other volumes that are supposed
to come after that
in this second apocalypse series
called the no god sequence we don't know
how many books are going to be in it you
know
some people say two we're still waiting
on backer to
bring those out nobody nobody actually
knows
at this point in time when those books
are going to arrive
it's sort of like george r martin um
song of ice and fire
who by the way back or as
being incredibly important he said that
that george r
martin as a speculative fiction writer
really
opened a lot of doors and made it
possible for
backer to be able to do the sort of work
that that he's doing
with the second apocalypse so there's
that
aspect the world building
is incredibly connected with in
important ways
with backers biography in
a number of different manners that we're
going to see intersecting with each
other
and you know there's some other aspects
as well
it's difficult to get hard information
on a lot of things in his biography just
going
online and nobody's written a biography
of backer as far as i can tell
so in a way he's almost sort of like one
of his own
characters who um you know
we know a lot about as they reveal
himself over time
maybe we'll learn a lot more in the
future so let's just jump right into his
biography
our step backer is born in simcoe
ontario
in 1967 so he's you know
roughly a contemporary for me he'd be
like an older
uh kid at school you know when i was at
school
myself and he you know we don't know
that much about
his own childhood he doesn't tell us an
awful lot about it unless there's parts
of his
blog that i haven't gotten to yet
but there is something that we can we
can say in 1984
he begins developing the world
yarwa the continent that all of the
things
all of the events all of the
developments in these stories
are happening in and so this is going
back
a long long way right
this is this is when he's essentially a
teenager
and before he goes to college so
he's in high school and how does it
happen
comes out of a dungeons and dragons
campaign
and so we should pause for a moment
and talk a little bit about the the
significance
of dungeons and dragons and fantasy
or even we could say speculative fiction
role playing
i'm guessing that quite a few people who
are watching this or listening to this
have actually participated in
role-playing games
um in whatever venue they they have i've
actually
you know i remember playing role-playing
games in middle and high school
and college when i was in the army
haven't done it too much since but but
it was something
very enjoyable and it was an incredibly
important part of my life
uh for quite a few years and i
imagine it was similarly so for for
backer
so d and d dungeons and dragons
was in the 1980s easily
the most successful and well-known
role-playing game it came out originally
from uh you know tabletop miniatures
games and got more and more complex over
time
there's a whole story to be told there
that i don't need to rehearse
i will say this by 1984
you had a really complete
system there were if i remember right
either five
or six actual books as opposed to like
little paperback things but hardcover
books that you could buy
you'd find them at hobby stores right uh
there was
the dungeon masters guide and the
players handbook and
monster manual and you know deities and
demigods and then there was there were
some other ones and i don't really
recall the names of them
and there was a world that you could
play in that that was sort of like the
official world gray hawk
which there was a giant map with with
hexagons on it
and all of these these places on the map
each with their own sort of ethnicity
and backstory and history
and you could play what we called
campaigns in those where you weren't
just
doing one single module but actually
like playing an entire world thing
and dungeons and dragons drew on a lot
of fantasy influences obviously tolkien
was a big deal you know they had to
rename hobbits halflings because the
estate
went after them robert howard's
conan and and other things fit in there
fritz lieber's fawford and the gray
mouser
you know and nuhon world were important
michael morcock we could go on and on
and on and on
as a matter of fact in gary gygax's um
dungeons master's guide there was an
essay about some of the
literature that one might read to get
ideas
and one of the cool things about d and d
as well as
so many other role-playing games is it
it
it had all this scope for the
imagination
in several different ways so each person
would create a player character
right and they would interact with
monsters and non-player characters
uh through the game master the dungeon
master and d
so you have to like engage in some role
playing and some people were good at
this some people were not good at it
others you know were were kind of
problematic because they were only
interested in like
maxing out their inventory or their
levels and they'd be what we call rule
lawyers and they were not not a lot of
fun to play with
but the people who or there were others
i will mention too
who want to be like show-offs you know
they they'd be kind of a drab doll
character
and then they'd they'd pick like an elf
and and it would be you know a female
elf and make her as sexy as possible
now that i remember that was a problem
with with uh gamers in
in the army of all places so they were
indulging something there but most
people were like you know i want to be
a cleric or you know a dwarven fighter
or
a ranger or do all all these sorts of
things and then you would act it out and
the
so you have to exercise your own
imagination and then you have the
game master who is also you know subbing
in for all these characters and monsters
and
setting up the scenario and running the
play
they have to have an incredible
imagination and they might develop an
entire
world in which your campaign could take
place
d was as i mentioned just the biggest
and most successful of these
kinds of games they weren't just
confined to fantasy
although there were some some real
interesting rivals one that was set
in i don't remember the name of it but
it was set in
the ancient world that existed on earth
and so you could be a roman or a
parthian or whatever
there was empire the petal throne which
was its own
really sophisticated well worked out
world building
game i never got to play that one there
was in space of course
uh games designer workshops traveler
which was really cool
there was gamma world you know a
post-apocalyptic world
there was boot hill for gunfighters all
sorts of things
like this and in the 80s this became
like big business and they started
rolling all sorts of things out there
was even a d d
cartoon which was not particularly good
and of course you may remember with the
satanic panic of the 80s
dungeons and dragons was also targeted
for that as a matter of fact there was a
there were movies about how like playing
dungeons and dragons might make you lose
your mind
why because the you know you're engaging
in
use of the imagination and you were
doing so in an interpersonal
way there was the actual gaming
and then there was you know reading the
texts involved with it and thinking
about all this sort of stuff
i mean there were game systems that i
read about
and never actually played but i remember
you know reading the books and thinking
oh cool i would set this up in this way
so backer is coming out of a context
in which all of this is
part of what you're doing and he's
reading literature
as well so that that's all part of it
this is in 1984 he first begins
developing this
1986 he goes off to college and roles in
the university of western ontario
begins studying literature beginning
studying literature is a bit of a
misnomer because really nobody becomes a
lit major
if they don't already love literature
you can become a philosophy major
without having read too much philosophy
i think it's more rare that somebody
becomes an english or lit major
without already having a you know solid
engagement with that
and while he's there he continues
developing this world
and the narrative for e.r wong the the
continent that this is on
and the second apocalypse he begins
developing out a
history and a history with many
different
perspectives and moving parts around
1990 it's a little bit hard to get
you know uh you know very conclusive
dates for this
he graduates with his bachelor's and
enrolls
as a master's student at the university
of western ontario
studying literary criticism and theory
and and so
that's getting you a lot of philosophy
stuff but it's also getting a lot of
history a lot of languages
so that that's kind of a good fertile
mix
that we'll talk about in a bit he also
encounters
some of the stuff that he's going to
criticize later on
uh under you know the rubric of say
postmodernism
then in 1992 we're guessing he graduates
with his masters
and then he goes down to the united
states and enrolls
in philosophy at vanderbilt university a
very good
university in the mid-south and he
stays there for about four years he
eventually
leaves vanderbilt never does finish a
dissertation
but you know when you've read enough
dissertations and then you compare it to
this i think he actually came out better
on the deal he retains a strong interest
in philosophy the entire time there is
one other thing i'll say about
vanderbilt too so
you know i've known quite a few people
from vanderbilt because i was at
southern illinois university and they
were all part of the mid-south region
vanderbilt around that time would have
had
a number of different people
representing
different philosophical traditions sort
of like it was where i went to school
at university of illinois carbondale he
would actually be leaving vanderbilt
shortly after i'm coming into carbondale
they're both what we call
pluralistic departments at that time and
as a matter of fact
you know we we actually had some people
hop back and forth from our school
and their school so um
he's continuing to work on all of these
interesting projects some of them
sort of straight philosophy you know
philosophy of mind consciousness
but also his his uh narrative that he's
got here
this is a good place to take a pause
um and and uh read a few things from
some interviews and excerpts
so he says uh in a in a
science uh yeah science fiction and
fantasy world interview
for the longest time i thought
publication was a pipe dream like saying
i want to be an astronaut in elementary
school
i sent the original manuscript of the
prince of nothing away
once in my early twenties i can't even
remember to whom anymore
it was rejected i remember that but even
then i think i looked down the whole
thing as an impossibility
i pretty much knew i lousy writer was
he's got this in quotes
and that the themes that i set myself
were beyond my ability to explore in
anything other than a hackneyed fashion
there was always this gap
between what i wanted to write the
reflections the feelings the tapestry of
actions
and what i was actually able to write i
never sent the manuscript out again
instead i started rewriting from the
very beginning
and elaborating and remolding the world
of erwa
and i continued doing this into my
mid-30s
at this point i regarded the project as
little more than an embarrassing
hobby i was living with my fiance sharon
and my dissolute ways had begun to
dissolve
i discovered philosophy the endorphins
were coursing through my veins
i was hell-bent on becoming a
professional academic
as strange as it may sound this is when
things
clicked for me writing-wise so
the you know the the prince of nothing
becomes this entire
three-book series and the darkness that
comes before
ends up being published in 2003 and this
is
a significant time after leaving
vanderbilt right abd
we say all but dissertation you know
you're supposed to be working
on your dissertation at the time and so
i think it's kind of you know
interesting he
he honed this he reworked it he also
became
you know when you read about him saying
oh you know i wasn't that good of a
writer
i couldn't you know get the characters
to do what i wanted
that's not here and this he he developed
his skills
in order to be able to to do that
so another thing that i want to bring up
here in terms of
his own writing is something a little
bit more big picture then we'll come
back to the biography this is in why
fantasy and why now
he tells us the power of science to
monopolize rationality has reached such
an extent that one can no longer ask
what's the meaning of life and still be
rational
thus the crisis of meaning the world we
live in has been revealed by science to
be indifferent and arbitrary where we
once lived in a world steeped in moral
significance
we now we live in a world where things
simply happen
where once the meaningfulness of life
was an unquestioned certainty
the very foundation of rationality now
we must continually struggle to make our
lives meaningful
and do so moreover without the sanction
of rationality
questions of the meaningfulness of life
have retreated into the fractured realm
of competing faiths
and the new age section of the bookstore
in our day
and age the truth claim my life as
meaning is as much an
act of faith that is to say a belief
without rational
legitimation as the truth claim there is
a god
so then he says it's no accident that
fantasy is preoccupied with our
pre-enlightenment pre-crisis past
the contemporary world is the nihilistic
world where all signs point to the
illusory status of love beauty goodness
and so on
this is not to say that they are in fact
illusory only
that at a fundamental level our culture
is antagonistic
to the claim that they are real nihilism
is a fever in the bones
of contemporary culture afflicting all
our assertions of meaningfulness
with the ache that they are wrong
fantasy is the celebration
of what we no longer are individuals
certain of our meaningfulness
in a meaningful world the wish
fulfillment that distinguishes
fantasy from other genres is not to be
the all-conquering hero
but to live in a meaningful world
that is a great way of describing what
the hell is going on in these books
there's you know faith there's
philosophy there's sorcery there's
you know the meaningfulness of one's own
life
and living out a history in which one
has been
bruised and damaged there's where you
fit
within uh you're jockeying for power
or prestige all of these things are are
being played out by these these
characters there's even the question of
well
you know is there any way out of this
cycle
and that's that's a question that's
being grappled with by some of the
other characters in addition to that you
have you know sort of a world historical
battle against evil not by good
but by people who are somehow less bad
right so there's all of these questions
that are going on and
we see you know in 2003 the darkness
that comes before
comes out 2005 the warrior prophet
continuing the story
2006 the thousand-fold thought so that
is
a lot of narrative within a very
short period of time around the same
time
backer also begins interacting with his
fans
at the three c's forum that that he
creates right the three c's are part of
the
narrative universe and
then he takes a bit of a hiatus he's
writing other stuff he's always
actually constantly writing but he
brings out another book that's not in
this series in 2008 called neuropath
that he retakes it up in 2009 with the
first of the unholy consult
the judging eye the next one in 2011
white luck
warrior and then in 2016 the great
ordeal and then finally 2017 the last
book in the series
the unholy consult in the meantime
however
he begins a wordpress blog called the
three pound brain in which he's
putting forth his ideas and speculations
and also interacting
with fans but but doing a lot of
philosophy of mind
in in the in the process uh quite a few
other books come out you know the
disciple of the dog
he's got some essays the blind brain
theory
the digital dionysus nietzsche and the
network-centric condition that are
coming out
and you know in 2017 he also published a
piece in the journal of consciousness
studies called
on alien philosophy and and it's quite
interesting to see
how well backer like you know quite a
few other authors that we've looked at
embraced the digital age and
used it in in ways that would allow him
to
very closely engage with with fans he's
actually got a really
great discussion of this here
in the future of literature in the age
of information
he says that literary authors need to
know their readers they need to identify
audiences possessing dissenting values
and attitudes
then they need to hijack or embrace the
narrative forms most commonly
marketed to them and here he says
something quite quite interesting about
you know
high literature and and you know
academic stuff
versus the much more widely read stuff
that you know fits into the genres like
like fantasy right he says
this means all the old and largely
unfounded prejudices against genre
fiction must be set aside
genre only seems antithetical to
literature
because the literary the academics the
opinion formers
have turned it into a flattering foil
abandon it in effect leaving a
rhetorical fog of self-congratulation
in their wake he's saying something
about our contemporary culture
he says in my own case i chose epic
fantasy
because i knew the best way to provoke
readers with a narrative meditation
on the nature and consequences of belief
was to reach
actual believers and provoke i did
other writers like chyna meowville
m john harrison gene wolfe john crowley
just to name a few are doing the same
thing producing works
that is obviously literary literary
openly provocative
yet unheard of in literary circles for
the simple sin
of wearing wrong wrong generic skin
these are the writers who are genuinely
shaking things up as opposed to hawking
intellectual and aesthetic buzzes inside
the literary echo chamber i think this
is actually dead on
a lot of the really important and
interesting stuff is not
happening in the you know high
literature
sanctum it's happening in in genre
literature
he says commercial genres must be seen
for what they are
relatively fixed channels of
communication to relatively dedicated
audiences
not as cages preventing some mythic free
expression
in in quotes right all channels of
communication force senders to play the
game to reach a given group of receivers
english is such a game the rules only
seem coercive
when you don't enjoy the game or if you
think it's stupid or beneath you
the literary author he's talking about
himself there
has to move past these old and
embarrassing conceits
the idea is to play the margins to play
the game well enough to be identified as
a trusted sender
by the receiver these are ideas in
communication theory right
all the while exploring ways to
challenge their background assumptions
and then he goes on and he says this is
no easy task
luckily now he talks about the internet
information technology has brought about
a curious and potentially revolutionary
reversal of the roles traditionally
assigned to
writers and readers before the internet
writers were almost exclusively
senders readers were almost exclusively
receivers
the effort required to contact an author
effectively restricted communication to
fan mail and cafe clutches is where
you'd get together and like drink coffee
and chitter chatter
and he said this assured that most of
the feedback a writer received would be
complementary something useful for
motivation
but not so useful for calibrating
communicative tactics
now every author living is simply one
vanity google away
from all stripes of unfiltered feedback
from blogs message boards
and special interest sites and he
mentions good reads
in there the internet allows a
contemporary author
to understand their readers better than
at any time in modern history
because it allows them to see the
consequences of their artistic decisions
right in a certain way people get mad
and they're like this sucks what's going
on with this character
and they may be off base but you can
like look at what they're saying
and get it in not not completely real
time but much closer time than
writing letters and then you can respond
to it and incorporate that and and
think about it and reflect on it so you
can you can say that
this series itself is in in large
respect
the product of a lot of workshopping a
lot of reflection
a lot of reworking and that these two
volumes
you know the warrior profit and the
thousand-fold thought as well as the
darkness that comes before
are in some respect reactions
to what he's trying out with with fans
as he builds
his narrative universe
to finish up with this biography backer
tells us that her backer uh
actually doesn't tell us anything that's
speaking there he's been largely
silent since uh 2017
and the arrival of the unholy consult
um you know the the finishing of that
segment of the second
apocalypse nobody really knows what's
going on because those
those blogs and message boards um
there isn't a lot of new movement on
them but there could be something else
in the works
we don't really know we have a lot of
material to discuss
so the next thing we should move on to
is this actual world
of arwa that backer created
at least the portion of it that we're
going to glimpse here
in the darkness that came before so
that's the darkness that comes before so
that means that we're going to talk
about geography we're going to talk
about ethnography we're going to talk
about history
we're going to talk about the uh
immediate situation we're going to talk
about the magic system
sorcery we're going to talk about the
religions there's a lot of interesting
things
for us to go into
in each of the three sessions that we're
going to devote to
this trilogy by r scott backer the
majority of the discussion
of world building is going to focus on
what
is revealed in each particular volume
and so there's going to be kind of an
expansion
of the world building going on and our
exploration of that
as more and more gets revealed
particularly through the thoughts
and the discourses of the characters and
also the places that they traverse which
require there to be
more discussion of what's going on and
i'm
doing that in part because i don't want
to try to
throw everything at you at once any more
than our scott backer
himself does however i should preface
this by saying that there are some
instruments you might say that are
provided in the works so the first thing
that i should mention
is that in the second and third volume
there is a section beginning
the the books which are really you know
quite helpful
which are uh just called what has come
before
and in those sections he's
not just narrating the plot but also
telling you
you know the important points that have
been revealed about the
the nature of the the world that um
that he's going to be detailing more and
more of in the second and third
volume i'll also point out as well
that each volume contains some
appendices that can be quite helpful
quite useful
there is of course a map you know it's a
fantasy book so there has to be a map
but there is a character in faction
glossary
there is uh major languages and dialects
of
arwa which is kind of useful as well
and then in addition to uh the maps
there's also
um akamian's map given
in this as well which is being
referenced at at numerous points
in this first book and in the other
books
a map in that case is not a map of
geography it's actually a map of
relations a mind
map as we would call it then in the
second volume the warrior prophet
you go towards the back and you will
find
another character in faction glossary
another map which is you know
they're mostly the same thing but in the
third volume
you'll find something a little bit more
it's an encyclopedic
glossary so this is our scott
backer for wow quite quite a few pages
actually
um here we go starts on page 405
of the work and it goes on to
page 503 so
almost 100 pages of discussion
of entries telling you more and more
about what's going on
so you know if you're the sort of person
who wants to have
a comprehensive understanding of that
you might actually jump to the third
book and you know fill yourself in on
all this sort of stuff
but if you're if you're reading the
works for the first time you might be
depriving yourself
of the process of having this you know
this world
um continually revealed to you so it's
it's up to you what you want to do
so all of that said let's talk about
what we get
in the darkness that comes before
i am going to say a few things about the
world that
are outside of the scope of the
narration
in in this work but just to help fill in
a few things
so everything is taking place
on this continent uh called you know
um erwa um and
he provides you maps you know of that
beyond that there's there's
you know another continent that's
separated from it from these these
mountains called
ayanna and that's where men originally
came from with the exception of one one
race of men who already lived in
iarwa so that's happening there and then
the the main action is happening
around what are called the three seas
so there's there's three bodies of water
that are connected with each other
there's all these
kingdoms around it they're mostly you
know well actually they are all human
kingdoms
because the other main races that are
involved in this really
they're not in those areas at all
and the continent um there's really two
we could say there's two parts of it
there's the high north
where humans used to live and a few
humans still do live
and that is dominated by these tribes of
of beastial creatures called the shrunk
uh we'll talk about them in just a
moment it's also where
the um you know some of some of the
important
factions that are going to be playing a
role like what's left of the consult
uh exist where the dunyan
exists and where some of the the non-men
also are living as well but we're going
to put that aside and then we have the
three
c's this southern area and then there's
other areas on the map
as well that are you know mentioned but
not really explored like zoum
uh we'll talk about that very briefly
but that's going to play a bigger role
not actually in these books but in
the four book series that follows
afterwards
so i mentioned races and
there we can talk about race in in two
different senses
in this work there's races as in
like ethnicities tied to
genetic characteristics of human beings
and then there's actual
other races involved as well
and we don't get to see very much of
them
early on we actually do see a
non-man um
encountered by kel huss the the
characters he's traversing his way
south but that's really about it but the
non-men
are going to turn out to be incredibly
important in the world
that we are exploring here and we'll
talk about
why in just a bit but they've been in
decline for a very long time
when they're encountered they're still
incredibly powerful
compared to human beings they had a
well-developed culture long before human
beings
even began began to be civilized right
and then there's another race um called
the
uh incari and they
were not originally from that planet
they they crash landed there there's a
whole story that'll be told
more in subsequent sessions but if
you're interested you can again jump
ahead to
the glossary at the end of book three
and they they fight a war with the
the non-men they also engage with
human beings in certain ways and they're
going to become what is later on
called the consult so we're going to put
that off for a bit
we've got these three main you know
races involved there but for the most
part the incari
and the non-men are just part of
backstory they're not really
raising their heads too much at this
point except in very limited
ways there's also uh
the weapon races and the only one of
these that we
really get to glimpse in in significant
detail are the shronk and the sronk are
sort of like human beings except they're
think about it sort of like a cross
between human beings and dogs in a way
and also
pigs smaller than human beings
um ravenous they they've got wires
crossed in their very brains that
associate
killing with sexual pleasure and
um they you know they're they're used as
a weapon against the non-men but they
also wind up being a very potent weapon
against human beings as well and
there's other weapon races that are
developed by the incari
using their their techne using their
capacity for breeding
these sorts of things these include raku
or dragons which can get quite
large in this this narrative universe
and be
you know supremely powerful um
other other you know very powerful
beings
the ones that are particularly important
for
this story are the skin spies and we
really only get to see
one or two of them in in the story right
they
they have this capacity to mimic
anybody's faces because their face isn't
a real face
it's really like a whole set of fingers
that can move around and manipulate in
different ways
and then take on the aspects of a human
being's face
and then there's something that's called
the synthesis which allows
some of the members of the consult to
live on in these things that have like a
human
head and bird-like body
and and you know sort of a repository
for their their minds
in addition to this there's the bosh
rock but we'll talk about them
more in in other cases so
those are the that's sort of the summary
of the different races now let's talk
about
human beings before that though we
should mention
there's there's a lot of backstory to
this um
and so we can break this up into two
main areas we could talk about
the we could call it the historical and
ethnographic stuff
and then we've got this other vaster
history
of the apocalypse and where we're going
this whole series is called the second
apocalypse as well so that's putting
things
into perspective and the main aspects of
world building that we want to attend
to before we talk about the the
apocalypse is
politics religion uh
issues of class the whole magic or
sorcery system
and then how philosophy plays a role
but i should mention and this is all i'm
going to say about it
here is that one of the things that
we're getting
through the the main character drusis
is or akka for short i'm just going to
call him akka from from this point on
which is the sort of term that essemet
uses for
for him um actually so other characters
who like him
he dreams every night of the
first apocalypse which has taken place
millennia before and he dreams the
life of sethwatha who was one of the
greatest
sorcerers of the time was
close friends with the high king
and who was part of this almost
decades-long period
that com that comprised the first
apocalypse he was
tortured by the uh what became the
mandate
he's um uh who are a member of another
uh
school that are that are allied with the
incari um
he sees the no god which we'll
we'll talk about a little bit more in a
bit who is
you might say a centerpiece of the
apocalypse
and this is part of what it means to be
a mandate
school man is that you dream these
dreams every night which allows you to
know about the ancient history and know
how bad it was
how horrifying things were and it's part
of the mission of the mandate and by
by framing it this way having uh
akamian talk about the dreams
and you know experience the dreams
backer is letting us
see what the ancient history was like as
well so he's giving us the lens
into how things are are going
let's talk about the races of of human
beings that plays an important role
in this there are essentially
six races of human beings two of which
really you know you're not going to get
any any main discussion of until
way way way later so they're not that
important this would be the
um mwama who were the slaves of the
non-men they were the native inhabitant
men of yarwa and we see them
much much later on in the the series of
four books
um then there is of the five races of
men who come
across the mountains through a gap and
then
invade uh as quite primitive creatures
uh when it's dominated by the non-men
um actually one of the one of the the
racism men don't cross over and those
are the
tsu gianni they dwell beyond the the um
cairos mountains so they don't play any
role in the story
but we have um four main races
of human beings there's the um
nosirai who are you know light-skinned
often blonde um blue eyed they live
in the in the high north and they are
the ones who
originally make friends with the non-men
who who there's a thing called the
non-men
tutelage where they're teaching the the
north sarai
and there's only remnants left
of of them we'll come to that in a
moment then there's the
ket yai the majority of the characters
and peoples
around the three c's that are taking
part in this this vast holy war that's
really the
centerpiece of this book are are
belonging to the ketyai
there is the satyothi who are
largely represented by this kingdom of
zeum
which we don't really learn much about
they don't they don't effectively play
a role and then there's the um skill
vendi
on the skill vendi are very interesting
they are you know fair-skinned uh
dark dark-haired and they are
essentially
a wandering nomadic predatory
people who live for war who view war as
a holy pilgrimage and fight against
everybody else and they were on the side
of the
the non-god the no god
uh and the the consult
what was going to become the consult
later on
during the apocalypse and so in a way
they're sort of like enemies of
all other men all over human beings
so you've got all of these things going
on and the the
the nursery sorry the nosirai
have largely been destroyed in the north
um the exceptions to this would be the
dunyan who have retreated into this this
stronghold that they have to carry out
their monastic
life and then two cities in that that
are still left in the north
uh atrithau and cecarpus carpus is going
to play a major
role in the later four books um
atrithyu is just a place for calhous to
you know
be at for a short time but he claims to
be the prince of calhouse
that's why he's the prince of nothing
right it's it's a city that nobody knows
anything about because it's so far
north it's away from the three seas
there are some
uh no surround nations around the three
seas galioth
um thunderous and kataidon
and they they contribute troops and
commanders and and
you know uh plot points you could say
to the holy war that's going to take
place because
all of the three seas are being united
uh against one of the the southern
kingdoms kion so that that's a good
segue into talking about the
uh katya so the caty eye are you know
more dark-skinned
um and you know darker hair brown eyes
that
that sort of thing the the biggest uh
kingdom is indeed kion which we're going
to talk about
in a bit because the holy war is
directed against them and so it plays a
very important role
then there's also the non-sur empire
which has lost a number of its provinces
to kion wants to get them back
it's sort of modeled after the
byzantines just like kian is sort of
modeled after
the you know muslim caliphate
and then we have uh other places like uh
konria which was at one time the center
of an empire
we have high ion uh which is also an
important place which is dominated by a
school of sorcerers that we'll get to in
a bit and then we have nila mesh which
is to the south of kion
and they're kind of their own show they
don't really enter much into
the uh the story in in these these works
um and so you know between the the
various
uh nosyria nations around the three seas
the
non-sur empire kian and um
uh konira and and i know we have
the big players what are often called
the great factions
in in this story so this is a good lead
into politics
what is the politics well um we have an
emperor
who is you know sometimes acknowledged
sometimes you know
not that acknowledged uh and it's he's
got his own court and all that and
then we've got these other countries
around the
three seas we've got kion to the south
which is fighting this this constant
battle
we have the scovendi raiding everybody
that they can and um
you know attacking them uh you know
the kianese have lost an important
battle against them the non-sir empires
lost
uh battles against them but they're
going to crush the skill vendi
under uh kony ross the nephew of the
emperor
in this and then what else we have
rivalries going on between all of these
other countries but they're being united
for a great holy war of all
of these nations against kion
and the empire is trying to take
advantage of this to you know require
uh the the provinces that are gained to
be given back
to them uh the other the other main
countries are not so into that
and there's an interesting discussion of
a game called benjuka
which gets brought up by cinemas
uh who is a uh uh konrian
uh noble and friend of uh
of uh jerusas uh akamian
and um actually they were they were
tutors
of proyeus who's a very important
character in this
when when they were younger and they
they they're friends
and they play this game together and
benjuka you have to imagine an
incredibly complex game where
the rules themselves change over time
and it's being used as a metaphor
for what's happening politically there's
a lot of political
machinations happening in this and again
how do we
how do we view this well backer has the
characters talk to each other about
their plans and their plots and what
might be going on the possibilities and
some of them are
mistaken about things as we're going to
talk about in a bit one of the key
themes
running throughout these works is
mistaking who your genuine enemies are
so there's all this political stuff
going on
and we should talk about religion next
since there's there's a unification
of sorts that's taking place because of
this
holy war so there's there's several
main religions that are coming up in
this
uh this storyline one
let's talk about keon so i mentioned
that that keon
as a country is largely modeled after
the muslim caliphate
and you know one of the things that we
can say about islam that's that's
similar to
uh what's called fonomiri which is
founded by this prophet
afane is that it's totally monotheistic
it's radically monotheistic it looks at
the
uh 1000 temples of the north and it says
that's idolatry there's only
one god and we have to you know stamp
out all of this this heathen stuff
and so they they go on jihads and
they're actually called jihads in this
book again
very similar connections and they take
over provinces and they including some
of the the main holy cities
of the other main rival religion
which uh is called um
in rithism uh founded by this this
prophet sajanis and and so jonas in
effect says listen there's all
these different cults and temples
they're all aspects of the same
one god so there's you know
why why do the phantom have a problem
with this because there's still
all of these different cults around
they're just unified into one
giant structure which has its own
overarching
political structure and treasury
and all of these other things going on
its own schools
uh the cults sometimes you know get a
little big for their britches as we're
gonna see
later on in some of these and
this goes back to a document which is on
a
literally a tusk the holy tusk written
you know when men were still young in
this script that that
it's like you know kept in the holiest
of holies and and the tusk
think of that as their bible right and
there's a lot of verses in the tusk
that say things like you know don't
allow [ __ ] to live stone them
sorcery is an abomination don't allow
the non-men to
to live because they're bad as well and
so you've got this um
this religious document and then all
these different cults
and and uh you know lowercase g gods you
could say that are all understood
as aspects of the one god now the
indrathism
does have a central figure who is called
the
shira and the shiraz are sort of like
popes right except
think of them as a pope presiding over
a whole host of other you know loosely
connected
religions and kind of keeping order and
sometimes the popes are corrupt
sometimes they're actually just tools
of the non-sir emperor so we see a lot
of the you know historical
uh uh you know holy roman emperor
versus the pope sort of thing or the you
know
the ruler of the eastern roman byzantine
empire and the patriarch
of constantinople or the other
patriarchies that you know he
he took over at different times um
we see a similar thing going on here and
in this case we have a
powerful shira mythonet
who declares a holy war against the
phanim and and at first they're worried
that the holy war is going to be against
the
schools of sorcery we'll talk about them
in just a moment but it turns out it's
against the phantom
and so nobles and people from all over
start gathering within the non-sur
empire
to go south and fight against the
phantom and they don't actually get that
far the first wave of them gets gets
wiped out
the vulgar holy war and by the end of
this book we
were getting ready to see the conflict
actually take place it's just been
gathering and marching
south the skill vendi also have their
own religion they
they worshipped the non the no god
and when the no god was destroyed they
they you know
continued to worship him
and all of that um continues to play a
really significant role
the skilvendi before they're effectively
defanged by
um the as i mentioned the brilliant
general
who is the nephew of the current empire
emperor they they go on pilgrimage
and they bring death and destruction to
the to the south
class also plays a role we mostly get to
see the nobles but we do get to see some
ordinary people smet for example as a
prostitute
you know other people have come from
less noble
beginnings there is this entire
structure you could call it an etiquette
called
nyan that plays a role in this and
there's all these different gradations
the people who are powerful generally
tend to be
for the most part obsessed with like
jockeying for
for power and prestige um quite a few of
them are a bit foolish
in in how they do that and so that
there's not that much more to be said
about that i think at this point we
really do need to talk about sorcery
though so sorcery plays an incredibly
important role in this and it's a major
feature of this
this universe sorcery originally
comes from the teaching of the non-men
to human beings of what they
learned of sorcery sorcery is a way of
using
language to change reality to bruise
reality and the gods don't really like
it and there are gods right
because it's changing the nature of the
universe that the gods created
the non-men in their time were very
potent
um sorcerers as a matter of fact
calhouse encounters a non-man
who uses some sorcery and that the the
um
uh you know the doing it the
bla here we go the dunya and i'm always
mixing these these funny names up
they actually think there is no sorcery
and so calhouse you know
encounters and it's like wow there this
stuff actually does exist
um ahmanian is is one of the most he
belongs to one of the most powerful
schools in terms of the kind of sorcery
that they have so
before we talk about these different
schools the people
the human beings that can do sorcery are
called the few they have a different
sort of insight
into reality a deeper insight into the
onta how things
actually are and they have the capacity
through
language and singing to to change those
sorts of things
when they do this produces something
called the mark
or a bruise upon reality
and so there there are several different
kinds of sorcery out there that play a
role in this
there's the gnosis which is represented
pretty much
only by the mandate one of the few
surviving schools
of the the high north where there was
this collaboration between
non-men and human beings the nosirai who
became
sorcerers there was another major school
of gnostic sorcery who went over to the
bad side with the inquiry
and eventually will become the consult
and the consult is sort of an alliance
between
incari renegade or
you know broken down non-men who who've
abandoned
uh their thing and we'll talk about why
that's the case later on in a different
session
and then human beings belonging to that
school
um who who joined them that becomes the
consult and so these two schools are
sort of rivals with each other but
nobody's seen the consult
for centuries and centuries as a matter
of fact
the mandate's not quite sure it's sort
of an article of faith for them that the
mandate exists but they don't really
know
as it turns out they do exist as we find
out in this then there
are the anagogic or an
agnostic um schools as well
the scarlet spires is one of these their
stuff is not as powerful as the gnosis
it's it's in some respect not as perfect
of a tool
right so a gnostic sorcerer can probably
face off against a number of anagogic
sorcerers and so this includes the
scarlet spires who are so strong that
they actually basically
control the kingdom of high ion
they are the the most potent of these
the the imperial
psych it's a you know a school of
sorcerers
who serve the empire and then there are
the mysunai
known as the mercenary uh sorcerers and
there are other schools that we find out
about but they don't they're they're not
mentioned really in in this
particular volume on the other side with
the phanem
fauna himself was the first of these
they are the sisaram
and they have a different thing going on
they've blinded themselves they see
through the eyes of little snakes
asps that they have in order that they
can
better see um the the the universe
as it is and they talk about the divine
water
they're letting that flow and what
they're doing is is a different kind of
sorcery
that doesn't leave a mark and so this
raises some some serious security issues
for
some of the other things particularly
the scarlet spires and there's a war
going on
at the beginning between the cesaro and
the scarlet spires in the background
also mentioned too that the other
schools often try to kidnap mandate
sorcerers to try to get the
gnosis from them then another really key
thing are what are called the trinkets
or the core eye
and this is the result of a another kind
of sorcery that's been lost
these are little balls that one carries
around with them and they can even be
fitted to arrowheads and then
shot at a sorcerer if they touch a
sorcerer
they turn the sorcerer into salt and
they so they're effectively sorcery
killers
and so long as they're held on one's
person they prevent that person
from being affected by sorcery uh so
that's an important
aspect as well the uh no god was
actually you know within a sarcophagus
that incorporated a lot of chorei so
couldn't be affected by sorcery at
all so that's a major major part of this
and we get a lot of explanations about
how sorcery works
in the course of this book but what
we're getting there is just sort of
pulling the curtain back compared to
what we're going to get
in the other books the system is quite
developed we'll say in our scott backer
the last thing that we should talk about
in terms of world building is the role
of
philosophers now there are some
philosophers who get mentioned at the
beginning of chapters
um there's there's all sorts of
interesting
things you know you've seen this in
you've seen this done by other authors
for example by um you know
in the dunes series right there's all
often times little things about this
so there's historians there's there's
philosophers there's also things from
drusis
akamian where he's telling the story and
he's kind of a philosopher himself but
they mentioned
to agence and then his his
disciple parkas who play a role the
non-men are supposed to have developed
philosophy on their own but we really
don't know much about it
there is however a lot of important
discussion in fact even
chapters devoted to this on the part of
the dunyan and we get a sort of like
here's how kel huss developed right
so who are these dunyan well they are
essentially monks but philosophers
who have withdrawn into a stronghold up
in the high north
after the destruction of the you know
the human empires
up there by the no god and the srank and
all these other you know
big baddies right they withdrew 2
000 years ago into their stronghold
and they are developing themselves
philosophically
also through martial arts also through
selective breeding
and their goal is to realize the
absolute
and so two main characters
are part of that um both of them
are are members of the um
so you could say they're descended from
the ruling
party of uh the the great north
uh actually one of the one of them plays
part of a
a prophecy right and um
there so each of them is their their
their surname is
ana surumbor and so kel host is the
younger one
his father mangus is down
in among the you know the the the the uh
keaney's and the sisaram uh
down in this holy city but they both
belong to this
important group that we're going to talk
about
in a bit because this is one of the
important philosophical themes
that we're going to expose in
this work so that's enough about the
world building i would say
there is a vast host of philosophical
themes that are
woven into this book the darkness that
comes before
no big surprise given backers
background in philosophy right
so there's all sorts of ethical
quandaries
and issues and distinctions
and a lot of epistemological stuff
there's plenty of metaphysics in here as
well
i i decided that in order to
try to keep it manageable i would talk
about
three main sets of of themes
and i associate each of these
with a particular main character of the
work
and indeed of the entire second
apocalypse
series so we have um ana sirembor
kel huss who is the prince of nothing
that the prince of nothing series is
named
after and this darkness that comes
before is part of the discourse is that
he's
centered within and so we can talk about
him
and his training as one of the dunyan
and then what happens when he goes out
into the world
as well as what happens with his father
ana surimbor
mungus so that's
really about the nature of philosophy in
a world that doesn't
know philosophy as such philosophy
as you could say both contemplative or
theoretical
and practical so that's one one key
theme
another i would say centers around
who the you know the one of the other
people who's
arguably even more of a main character
and that is jerusalem akamian
right the mandate schoolman
and sorcerer who is also a spy who
follows along
with the the holy war the lover of
essemet and um
what can we what can we call that theme
it's
it's it's an epistemological theme
dealing with knowledge but again there's
a practicality to it
and we could say that one of the the
key questions of this is well what is
actually going on
and how do we know this to be the case
particularly as we go deeper and deeper
and deeper into what is
truly happening behind the scenes and
this is a you know very common sci-fi
and fantasy and horror theme it's it's
sort of a
mainstay of speculative fiction you know
plots within plots within plots and
revelations so i would say knowledge
trust and who the real threat or enemy
is is is the theme to associate with uh
akamian and then we have uh
uh knighter the self-proclaimed
most violent of men the skill vanity
and there we can talk about conflict
death war and it's its role
as violence but also
intellect so we have in some respect
three different
three different i don't want to say
philosophies as like world views
although they are different world views
but
um approaches to the use of the
human mind are articulated in this and
all three of them
are indeed they have a theoretical
dimension to them but they're all
inherently practical
so let's talk first
about the dunyan this this uh
you know people who have withdrawn into
a stronghold
up in the high north after the first
apocalypse and have been engaging
in training the dunyan are people who
are as
as they say surrendered to the logos
and and what is uh the logos and what
does it mean to be
surrendered to it um so here's from
calhous himself he says the dunyan
have surrendered themselves to the logos
to what you would call
reason and intellect we seek absolute
awareness
the self-moving thought the thoughts of
all men
arise from the darkness if you are the
movements of your soul
and the cause of that movement precedes
you then how could you ever call your
thoughts your own how could you
be anything other than a slave to the
darkness
that comes before the title of this very
book right
and he says only the logos allows one to
mitigate that slavery only knowing the
sources of thought and
action allows us to own our thoughts and
actions to throw
off the yoke of circumstance and only
the dunyane
possessed this knowledge plains men he's
talking to kanaya right he's explaining
things
the world slumbers enslaved by its
ignorance only the dunyan are awake
mengis my father threatens this and
this is a really key theme so you know
this ties in with this notion of
you know is philosophy supposed to be
primarily
speculative contemplative theoretical
or is it something that while it has
that aspect that's within a larger
practical frame and you can say so long
as you don't know
why you're doing theoretical philosophy
or
any other thing for that matter you're
in some respect kind of a prey
to all the outside forces that are
causing you to do
what you do or the composition of your
mind how you're handling trauma how
you're making sense out of your own
history and so that is what these these
people are attempting to do
and we get to see kel huss getting
trained in this
in chapter 17. i'm not going to talk too
much
about this just to keep this fairly
short but that is
that is a key chapter to look at um
so there's there's here here's a a great
example
he's told as a young boy you know to
meditate on the logos is without being
beginning or end he has to do this over
and over and over again
and as he does it he says long afterward
he would realize this
exercise that demarcated his soul the
incessant repetition of the pragmas
proposition
pitted himself against himself shown him
the extent to which he was other to
himself
for the first time he could truly see
the darkness that had preceded him
and he knew that before this day he had
never truly
been awake and so
this puts him at an incredible advantage
over other human beings uh the dunyan
are like adults to
to children as uh kanye realizes
um calhous early on in the book we have
you know what comes before
determines what comes after dunya and
monks spent their lives immersed in the
study of this principle
illuminating the intangible mesh of
cause and effect that determined every
happenstance
minimizing all that was wild and
unpredictable because of this events
always unfolded with granted
certainty in issual right
and he says to know what would come
after was the beauty that still the
hallowed communion of intellect and
circumstance
the gift of the logo so by engaging in
this this sort of study that gives him
you know all sorts of other advantages
to you know
being able to be a great martial artist
he acquires an insight into human
psychology he's able to
he's able to pull at the strings he's
able to
tell what's going on what's motivating
people he can't do it always
you know immediately at once there he
has to make certain approaches to it
right just as much as his
his father did with canair uh 30 years
earlier i want to bring up something
else about this self-mover thing
so there is somebody else who's
mentioned
as a self-mover in this or at least
not as a self-mover but in terms of not
being moved by others
and that is the imperial
general uh general exalt confis right
um his his uncle serious is
is thinking about this he says his never
his nephew was never moved by another
confis was moved by confis even if at
times in mimicry of being moved by
others
he was a man for whom everything was a
whim a perfect man
now is he really a perfect man or is
this the flawed perspective
of the the emperor that's going to turn
out that way
kel huss a little bit later in the book
we find
this nice passage here it is
where here
uh calhouse himself is
one of the people who is able to
move the souls of of men
and how is uh
finding this out by teaching calhous
right so that's that's a pretty
important he's a calhouse is a person
who can move the souls of others
and later on in towards the very end of
it you know remember calhouse's goal
is actually to take over the holy war
and use it as an instrument to
get to chamele to his his father here's
the last thing we'll say
for calhouse each of the great names
represented a question
a juncture of innumerable permutations
in their faces
he saw fragments of other faces
surfacing as though all men were but
moments of one man
an instant of luth passing like a squall
through
jerry's skull as he argued with salbone
a glimpse of surway in the way gothilek
looked on his youngest son the same
passions
but each cast in dramatically different
balance any one of these people
might be as easily possessed as lewis
had been despite their fierce pride
but in their some they were incalculable
they were a labyrinth
a thousand thousand halls and he had to
pass through them
he had to own them so he had to be able
to
figure out what as we say make people
tick what motivates them
and then get them all going in the the
right direction and this is an
incredibly complex
problem so that's that's uh one
really important thematic let's say of
the work
let's turn now to akamian because he's a
really interesting character he's a
mandate sorcerer so he's
you know very powerful at the same time
it
gets kicked around and off a lot in part
because of the circumstances
you can't you can't solve most problems
with sorcery
and he's also a spy he's uh
detailed on missions by the mandate
who are in this you know war that
they're not even sure is still
going on because they're not sure that
the consult still exists
and one of the key issues in in this
work
is knowing who the real enemy is as it
turns out the consult does still exist
and they
are far more evil than any of the people
that you might elevate as being evil if
you're the you know the northern
uh parts of the three c's the you know
the phoneme you see them is evil but
they're not really
evil uh the way that the consult is who
want to raise the know god the srank are
clearly evil you know this monster race
of
of sub-human things the non-men
you know they're they're arguably at
certain points evil that certainly
the in rhythm cast them that way but you
notice what what
well and the the different groups of of
sorcerers you know the
uh scarlet spires think that it's the
sisaram
who are you know sending the skin spies
and all that the
same with the empire so there's a lot of
misrecognition of who the real
enemy is and it turns out that the
mandate
uh was right all this time
the consult this group of people of
that are you know sort of a
incorporation of these evil
sorcerers from a previous
agnostic school
the non-men who have become erratic and
the incari who are
horrible things to begin with are out
there and are manipulating things
as things are going on so akhmanian
finds this out and part of how he
discovers this
is one of the skin spies who calvos is
able to see because he can see that this
this thing doesn't really have a face it
just has
you know these finger-like things that
can set up expressions that fool people
now akhmanian himself
has a lot um a lot of tools at his
disposal
and you know there's a couple things
that get get
brought up here there are a couple
passages i wanted to to call attention
to
so the first one is early on in the book
and it's about the great factions
and the mandate itself he says
how could he not be cynical in the three
c's all the great factions
ward with tangible foes for tangible
ends well the mandate ward against a foe
no one could see for an end no one
believed in this made mandate schoolmen
outcast not only in the way of sorcerers
but also in the way of fools
of course the potentates of the three
c's katyai
and norsaraya alike knew of the consult
and the threat of the second
apocalypse but they did not believe
after centuries of skirmishing with the
mandate
the consult had simply disappeared
vanished no one knew why or how
though there had been endless
speculation had they been destroyed by
forces unknown
had they initially annihilated
themselves from within or had they
simply found a way to elude the eyes of
the mandate it had been three
centuries since the mandate had last
encountered
the consult for three centuries they'd
waged a war without a foe
so that's part of the backdrop he also
engages in this interesting
process of what we nowadays recognize as
mind mapping and this starts
on page 267 and you know goes through
to uh here we go page two
seventy uh and i'll just read a little
bit of this he says akmanian often made
such maps not because he worried he
might forget something
but because he was worried he would
overlook something
visualizing connections he found always
suggested
further possible connections moreover
this simple exercise that often proved a
valuable guide for his inquiries in the
past
so you know he's he's trying to map out
all the
things that are connected to each other
as a matter of fact the uh there's
there's a map of it contained in one of
the
appendices in the back another thing
that i brought up earlier is this
uh this game uh banjoka and there's some
discussion of it here we go
benjuka was a relic a survivor of the
end of the world that had been played in
the courts of tirsa
a trio and met sonk before the
apocalypse
much as it was now studied in the
gardens of karat sal
nenkophan and moment but what
distinguished benjuka was not its
age in general there was a troubling
affinity between
games and life and nowhere was this
affinity more striking or more
disturbing
than in benjuka like life games were
governed by rules
but unlike life games were utterly
defined by those rules the rules
were the game and if one played by
different rules one simply played a
different game
since a fixed network a framework of
rules determined the meaning of every
move as a move games possessed a clarity
that made life seem a drunken brawl by
comparison
right the cunning of benjuka lay in the
absence
of this fixed framework rather than
providing an immutable ground the rules
of banjoka were yet another move within
the game
yet another piece to be played and this
made benjuka the very image of life
a game of baffling complexities and near
poetic
subtleties other games could be
chronicled as shifting patterns of
pieces
and numberstick results benjuka gave
rise to
histories and so benjuka itself is sort
of a metaphor for
what akhmanian is trying to discern
through this and what kel ha
kel hos is trying to make sense of as
well this shifting pattern of human
history in this case of course
calhous is motivated by the logos and
finding his father
and taking over the holy war for his own
purposes akhmanian is motivated by a
whole host of concerns
including love for for different people
his students
for essmet the horror of the
apocalypse that he revisits every night
in his dreams
as ceswatha who lived through the
apocalypse
and he's got to try to get through
to the right people about what's going
on
in another passage that i want to bring
up he talks with uh proyess who
he had been the teacher of um and he
tells him that the holy war
might not be what it seems and then
prayer says oh with mock astonishment
not what it seems for the emperor the
holy war is a lectrous means to restore
his empire for so many of my peers
it's simply a venal instrument of
conquest and glory
for uh eleazaris and the scarlet spires
it's a vehicle for some arcane who knows
what and for so many others it's a cheap
way to redeem a squandered life
the holy war is not what it seems there
hasn't been a night ahmadi
akami on when i haven't prayed that
you're right the crown prince leaned
forward and poured himself a bowl of
wine
and then he says prayers are never
enough are they something will happen
some treachery or small atrocity
and my heart will cry fly on this damn
them all and you know what
a kamian it's a possibility that saves
me that drives me to continue
what if i ask myself what if this holy
war
is in fact divine a good in
and of itself ahmanian says that's
impossible but
this is his former student and instead
there's a different kind of holy war
that's going on that akhmanian is trying
to
to chart out so you know there's there's
a lot
to unpack there let's jump now however
to one of the other great characters
sketched out in here and that is
i want to get his full name right uh can
i use kyota
right or we'll just call it uh after
this
the most violent of men and one of the
skill vendi
chieftains uh chief of the tribe of the
uttamat who is going to be
wiped out now he is
a very interesting character because
he gets led astray from the
traditional skil vendi way of living by
this
this uh donaian right who
is there and becomes a slave of him
and what we see going on here
is that he gets a metaphor
laid out for him a metaphor of the
the grasslands the steeps
and the the scovendi
are very tradition bound they do the
same
thing over and over and over again
and here we go mangus spoke about many
things over the months that followed
about how men slumbered about how the
logos the way of intellect was the only
thing that could awaken them
but all of it was a blur to kanir now of
all their secret transactions he
remembered only the first with any
clarity
when the warriors raid the empire across
the mountains manga said they always use
the same trails do they not
yes of course but why can't i were
shrugged because the trails are mountain
passes there's no other way to cross
into the empire
when the warriors gather to raid their
neighbors pastures they always use the
same trails do they not
no why not because they ride over open
ground
the ways of crossing the steep are
without number
exactly mengis exclaimed and is not
every task
like a journey every accomplishment a
destination every hunger a point of
departure
so he says here we go make your point
slave
do you see you grow impatient because
you think the path i take too convoluted
even words are like journeys
so if all things men do are journeys
there's the master metaphor
i ask you why are the ways of the skill
vendi the customs that bind what men do
like mountain passes why do they ride
the same trails over and over again
when the ways to their destination are
without number
here we have something really
interesting going on for some reason
this question thrilled knighter
the words were so audacious he felt bold
for simply hearing them
so compelling he felt at once
exhilarated and aghast
and though they had touched a place that
ached to be touched
the more because it was forbidden the
ways of the people he'd been told were
as immutable and sacred as the ways of
the outlander were fickle and degenerate
but why
weren't these ways simply trails used to
reach similar destinations
what made the schovendi way the only way
the only track an upright man might
follow
and how could this be when this when the
trackless steep dwelt
as the memorialist said in all things
skill vendi
for the first time kenauer
saw his people through the eyes of an
outsider
how strange it all seemed right he says
for the first time he truly asked why
and this liberates him in a very
interesting way it also winds up being a
trick and a trap
at the same time this corrosive effect
of asking why of reason that we see
in in philosophy leads to a kind of
nihilism doesn't it now
we also find out that uh in the battle
between
the imperial forces uh led by corphus
and the the uh skill vendi when the
scovendia are
essentially broken and destroyed
he's there on the battlefield and he
gets to hear a discourse
between martimos and confus
and so martimus says
here we go um
[Music]
oh actually actually we'll skip ahead a
little bit here um
confis says that if i were to tell you
all that i know you'd still suffer the
same deficit
answers are like opium the more you
imbibe the more you need which is why
the sober man finds solace and mystery
and then martima says at the very least
you could explain to me
how you could have known that we'd win
so here's what confidence says
as i said the skill vendi are obsessed
with custom that means they repeat
martimus
they follow the same formula as time and
again do you see they worship war
but they have no understanding of what
war truly is
what is war truly intellect
martimus war is intellect this is
something that that
um kenair is hearing as he's laying
there being mistaken for a corpse and
this is going to
be repeated when he has his his sort of
conflict between of words essentially
between
uh the exalt general being put to put
out as you know the
the champion the leader of the holy war
and where he's being proposed as a
leader as well
um the holy war is is really
this you know this massive thing that is
is being
substantified it's a host of human
beings it's also a direction
and the question is who is going to
manage it who's going to
run it who's going to animate it with
intelligence
and there's a number of different
possibilities there's the nancer empire
right
and you know uh confis has just been
successful over the skill vendi he seems
like
just the person to lead his troops love
him will follow him to the death are
loyal to him rather than to the empire
then um there's there's prius right
and prayeus represents real faith not
the fake faith of the emperor
and prayers proposes something different
instead
this is towards the end where we're
seeing this this culmination of this
great
war council and
here we go um project says the great
names lead
the skill vendi will be our advisor and
then the
emperor says an outrage still an army
with 10 generals when you found her
and you will for you no not the cunning
of the kianin to whom will you turn a
skill vendi
and then uh project says you'd speak of
outrage to us huge school in piety those
who'd sacrificed their very lives for
the tusk
what of your iniquities a curry what if
you would make a tool
of the holy war and they're they're
going back and forth
then what does the skill vendi actually
have to say
in all of this what does he contribute
he gives a speech after a lot of back
and forth that's quite important
here we go
he's being asked what he's going to do
and he says um
[Music]
i was without my tribe so i accepted the
wager of kel huss and then they say what
wager
and the wager is that this war would be
unlike
any other it would be a revelation the
war is a religious phenomenon
and then uh ghatian who's the
representative of
uh mythonet the the shira right he says
i see
and kanye says do you i do not think so
i remain a skill vendi
do not mistake me in rithi in this much
confess is right you are all
staggering drunks to me boys who would
play at war
when you should kennel with your mothers
you know nothing of war war
is dark black is pitch it is not a god
it does not laugh or weep
it rewards neither skill nor daring it
is not a trial of souls nor the measure
of wills
even less is it a tool a means to some
womanish end
it is merely the place where the iron
bones of the earth meet the hollow bones
of men
and break them you have offered me war
and i have accepted
nothing more i will not regret your
losses i will not bow my head before
your funeral pyres i will not rejoice at
your triumphs
but i have taken the wager i will suffer
with you i will put phantom to the sword
and drive their wives and children to
the slaughter
and when i sleep i will dream of their
lamentations and be glad
of heart now what's going on there this
is sort of you know almost like
conan you know what is good in life or
driving your enemies and hearing the
lamentations of their women kind of
kind of moment this is the product
of the people of war having been
influenced by the logos
by what that makes available
canias is a different kind of skill
vendi but he is a skil vendi
what we have here in these three
characters and in the three themes that
i've just laid out
are you might say approaches to
different kinds of wisdom
that all are connected with each other
play off of
each other but reveal different sides
of reality and human history
that's part of what is woven into this
pretty amazing book and i think with
that
this is a good place for us to
end this particular discussion some of
these themes will come up again
and be reworked in the next two volumes
as well and there's plenty of other
really important philosophical themes
that we're going to
introduce in addition to those as well
[Music]
you